another Victory with the black pieces
after the one against Jeffrey this is an
important one coming into this game uh a
pack of hungry wolves behind you only
half a point how important was for you
to get this Victory with black
pieces yeah I thought this was a game
that I really should be fighting for the
win potentially uh I didn't want to go
crazy but I I thought uh especially if
Andrew plays this line then we're going
to get a big fight and he has shown the
intention to play this line and I had a
rare idea in the opening Knight
H5 uh deviating from his game against
Levon where which repeated with Bishop
G7 Knight B5 so this was a rare and
interesting idea rather risky of course
but also if white doesn't know what to
do it's it's very interesting and he he
clearly was caught off guard a bit he
didn't really react in the best way I
think Bishop D3 is a very dubious move
and then Bishop H4 is uh is a even more
dubious move yeah he was
shuffling these last few moves with his
Bishop he actually made five moves with
the bishop in a row and allowed you to
break in the center and get that Queen
to B6 a lot of tension in the position
how did you assess it after this move
Queen to
B6 I thought this was much better maybe
borderline winning for black it is I
could also take on D4 and play knight6
which is better for black like my first
intention was okay knight6 and queen
goes back and D4 and Knight goes back
and of course I'm much better but then I
saw Queen B6 is perhaps uh even more
devastating for him yeah and then I
think I didn't play well I mean okay
Knight of5 is definitely correct like
for for a few moves I probably played
correctly but then I think I lost some
of the advantage like maybe here
somewhere uh yeah maybe F5 yeah I spent
some time on it and um I thought that
like if I play F5 and then Rook B1 Queen
D4 I get a better version of the end
game but of course I should Chase his
King to to F1 my first intention and the
thing is after King F1 Queen D4 take
take I saw like Rook B1 and then Knight
F3 and I I didn't want to start wasting
time with my pieces Bishop B7 Knight F3
C5 but but of course it's very important
that he can't castle Yeah but I was a
little bit unsure if this was a better
version or what we had in the game and
finally I went for what we had in the
game I regretted it somewhat but it was
still overwhelming at this
point I wasn't so sure like if he plays
uh Rook A1 instead of Rook
C1 uh also also after U Bishop B6 yeah
A1 Bishop D5 Castle Bishop G7 C3 of
course I'm up a pawn it's much better
but the draw drawing margin in chess is
rather high and he can start to both
trade Bishops with Bishop F3 and also
play Rook A5 Rook A1 so I felt like I
didn't um play this too ideally and then
he played Rook C1 and and I think after
that Bishop H6 is a very devastating
move yeah uh maybe among other moves but
I I didn't really
see um I thought okay instead of H4
probably King F1 is the most tenacious
uh on move what was it 25 I guess King
F1 but I thought Bishop D2 Knight D2
Knight C3 this is what convinced me to
play Bishop H6 when I when I played it
because okay my Bishop's trapped but
with this I save it and his King on F1
is of course also in big trouble
so yeah at this moment I was pretty
confident absolutely an important
victory for you Fabiano congratulations
definitely you're setting up um a good
trend for this tournament try to defend
the title we'll see it
tomorrow our congratulations as well
Fabby well we're getting a lot of
results this round five I mean that rest